تتصدر قوه الحريه والتغيير مجموعه المجلس
المركزي المكونات السياسيه السودانيه
المؤيده للاتفاق الايطالي وتضم المجموعه
حزب الامه القومي والتجمع الاتحادي وحزب
البعث الاشتراكي وحزب المؤتمر السوداني
الى جانب جناح من تجمع المهنيين وجناح من
الجبهه الثوريه بقياده هذه الادريس على
الجبهه الاخرى من قوه الحريه والتغيير نجد
الكتله الديمقراطيه الرافضه للانتفاق
الايطالي وتدعوا للعوده الى الوثيقه
الدستوريه لعام 2019 مع اجراء اكثر من 30
تعديلا عليها
ابرز مكونات هذه الكتله الجناح الثاني من
الجبهات الثوريه بقياده من الكناوي وحركه
العدل والمساواه والتحالف الديمقراطي
للعداله الاجتماعيه وبعض اجنحه الحزب
الاتحاد الديمقراطي وغيرهم من الرافدين
للاتفاق الاداري ايضا تحالف اهل السوداني
للوفاق الوطني الذي عقد مؤتمرا جامعا ده
مينه باعلان سياسيا ومسوده للسور يضم
التحالف قوه من التيار الاسلاميه العريض
ابرزها الحركه الاسلاميه وحركه الاصلاح
الان والاخوان المسلمون اما تحالف التغيير
الجذري فهو كذلك من الرافدين للاتفاق
الايطالي ويرفض بشده العمليه السياسيه
القائمه على التفاوض مع المكون العسكري
يتالف هذا التحالف من الحزب الشيوعي
السوداني وجناح من تجمع المهنيين اضافه
الى هيئات مهنيه اخرى
خامس هذه المكونات تنسيقيه لجان المقاومه
وهي تنظيم قاعديون بلا قياده موحده ينتشر
في ولايه الخرطوم وعدد من المدن السودانيه
وتنقسم المواقف داخل هذه التنسيقات حيث
يؤيد بعض لجانها الاتفاق الايطالي في حين
ترفضه لجان اخرى وتدعو لمواصله المظاهرات
المناهضه له وللعسكريين في السلطه